these are some of europe's most popular
holiday destinations
but not like we're used to seeing them
vast slaves of tourist towns in the
mediterranean are ablaze
in turkey more than 100 wildfires have
erupted since wednesday
water cannon usually reserved for
controlling riots
instead being used by emergency services
to tackle a blaze threatening to engulf
the city of bodrum
authorities in the country say most of
the fires are under control
but a handful rage on
for those being evacuated the relaxation
of a holiday was replaced by panic
as flames descended on coastal resorts
our nation should be at ease we will not
allow any of our citizens to suffer
we will cover all the damages forest
fires in our country doubled after
leaders of the terrorist organization
pkk gave the order to bernard forest
last year
we do not rule out that these fires were
started by a similar instruction
turkey's president suspects some of the
fires may have been started deliberately
but it's hard to ignore the specter of
rising temperatures across southern
europe
there are also heat waves in other areas
including here
in sicily this beach resort close to the
town of catania
was turned to charred remains while
firemen battled dozens of wildfires in
the area
emergency services have asked for
reinforcements from rome
similar scenes in greece too where
flames fanned by strong winds
raced down slopes and threatened seaside
villages
tourists can leave but the people who
live here
have to deal with this homes crops and
livelihoods destroy
as temperatures rise and the effects of
climate change continue to be felt
scenes like this will only become more
common
shingi mararike sky news